i have an idea that's so crazy it might
just be true
let's talk about king the conqueror and
immortus for a second a lot of people
are confused about this king the
conqueror and immortus who are basically
the same person yet somehow two
distinctly different people
let's use captain america steve rogers
as a way to explain how these two
characters function so we know the
timeline of steve rogers right steve
rogers was a really scrawny kid in the
1930s that he always wanted to enlist as
a soldier in world war ii he was
eventually given the super soldier serum
blasted with vita race he fought during
world war ii piloted a great big ship
and then was frozen
in ice for 70 years he was thought out
then he became a member of the avengers
then he fast forward to avengers end
game when he took the infinity stones
and the hammer of thor
back to where they were supposed to be
keeping the timeline intact and then
came back to the present day
after having lived a life with peggy
carter let's say he didn't let's say
that in that time when he went back and
lived the life of peggy carter he
created a name for himself he started
calling himself
tim and he led a whole life as tim his
whole life with peggy carter that he had
the idea that he was steve rogers but
ultimately looked at that as
a previous life for himself that that's
not his life anymore he's not captain
america he's not an avenger he's tim and
he has a life with peggy carter and he's
doing whatever he's doing with peggy
carter and then when the time comes when
she develops alzheimer's and ultimately
dies instead of coming back to the
modern era he just
lives out the rest of his days as tim
and then eventually dies of old age with
maybe children grandchildren whatever
the case happens to be
that's how immortus and kane the
conqueror work but technically
all these different characters who are
out there iron lad and mortis
rama tut they're all based off the
character of kane the conqueror who went
back in time at different periods across
the universe's history and then they
just kind of fashioned a life for
themselves and live out that life
as that particular person jonathan
magers is the guy who's supposed to play
king the conqueror in ant-man and wasp
quantum mania if you saw immortus it'd
be played by jonathan majors
sure they're the exact same person in
terms of look but in terms of
personality and life experiences they're
completely different people that's why
you would have immortus and kang talking
to each other
as if they were different people despite
more or less being the same person
now with that out of the way let's talk
about this crazy idea because i felt
like that needed to be explained
particularly with what we're going to
talk about here
so in the episode 4 promo of loki you
have
sylvie as a little girl by all standards
of measurement is her there's no reason
to believe that it's not her now sylvia
as a little girl looks exactly the way
that loki would look
the big question you have to ask here is
why is sylvie as a little girl
being brought into the tva the time
variance authority exists to ensure that
those individuals who become variants or
deviate from the existing timeline are
quote unquote dealt with
effectively according to mobius they're
killed which indicates to us that mobius
doesn't actually know what happens to
them because we know by virtue of sylvie
assuming that she's telling the truth
that they're turned into members of the
tva and they just go forward as agents
having their minds wiped and new
memories put in their place
so silvie would likely have been turned
into a tva agent
for whatever reason that happened to be
my bet is she's not supposed to exist
but there could be something bigger at
play here so let's say that sylvie is
turned into a tva agent
she exists as an agent and then does
whatever it is that tva agents do
depending on when she was part of the
organization somewhere along the line
she went from sylvia the tva agent to
sylvie who hates tva agents specifically
the tva itself seems like she's
timekeepers she wants to take the
timekeepers out we don't definitively
know if that's the case
because she seems to have routinely said
this is not about the timekeepers it's
much bigger than that my guess
is the timekeepers are dead with the
exception of one
so my thought here is silvie was brought
into the tva
because as we know with mobius talking
to loki that variants are
breakaways from a guaranteed outcome for
a particular timeline this sacred
universe
has a guaranteed beginning and a
guaranteed end and the whole goal of the
tva is to
stop those alternate realities from
coming into existence a nexus event
happens
and alternate reality branches off when
it reaches the red line it is officially
an alternate universe and that alternate
reality cannot be
undone hence the purpose behind the
reset charges i believe the theory that
a lot of you guys have
that king the conqueror is the one who's
secretly running the show that king the
conqueror and the time keepers engaged
in a great big huge multiversal war and
kang the conqueror
actually came out on top that begs the
question what happened to the time
keepers are they totally destroyed
i would say all the time keepers are
dead except for one that one time keeper
is alive
and that timekeeper comes in the form of
miss minutes that miss minutes is the
missing timekeeper here that they were
all basically destroyed or eradicated or
whatever the case was and in the time
where the timekeepers were being
eliminated
one of them maybe backed up their memory
and missed minutes or whatever the case
happens to be so here's a real question
you have to ask here in terms of why
would a time keeper pretend to be miss
minutes well if we're talking about a
timeline right an entire universal
history
and king the conqueror sits at the end
of it and presumably knows how it's
going to begin and how it's going to end
a time keeper would be aware of that as
well they would know all the strengths
and all the weaknesses of being
in king the conqueror's position there'd
be nowhere in the timeline
they could possibly hide nowhere in the
timeline where they could go
that king the conqueror couldn't find
them so what better alternative than to
basically
hide outside of time than to hide in a
place where king the conqueror
doesn't know where they're going to be
he doesn't know the exact place that
they're going to arrive when you're
at the very end of time and you know how
the line's going to play out all king
the conqueror would have to do
is meet that time keeper before they
ever arrived in that particular location
and then take them out we know the time
variance authority exists
outside of time they exist in null space
or at least supposedly no space there's
a big fan theory out there that they're
actually existing in the quantum realm
and king the conqueror is the one who
rules the quantum realm i don't know if
that's definitively the case
but if it really is king immortus would
have you who's running the show there'd
be no way they could hide in the time
stream
so if they hide outside the time stream
the only place to do that is to either
hide outside of the entirety of the
multiverse itself
in which case they'd have no real
ability to influence the end
of kang's entire rule or they hide
inside the time variance authority
more so than that you hide in plain
sight you hide where nobody would expect
you
you hide in the form of miss minutes and
if this time keeper knew just by virtue
of knowing the time stream
that sylvie is a nexus being she'd be
the perfect person to bring in
because in turn she'd be able to create
all kinds of chaos we know that just by
virtue of the statement that was made
that the universe wants to break free
the universe creates chaos
people like me so i don't know if that's
definitively the case
it could just be that it's one of these
things where sylvie just kind of exists
but miss minutes
is the reason why sylvie went from being
a tva agent presumably as a little kid
to becoming the sylvie that we know now
and the sense that miss minutes
basically woke her up now the question
is why what would be the point what
would be the reason for doing that
why sylvie in particular because i think
that if the timeline is a guaranteed
outcome
and the sacred timeline is predicated on
the idea that that's seemingly the only
universe of the only timeline
where cain the conqueror actually was
victorious and in
all the other alternate realities he was
basically defeated in the same capacity
as doctor strange looking at alternate
universes and only one of them was where
thanos was defeated when iron man died
that cain the conqueror is seeking to
keep that as the singular
universe out there so he never has to
worry about the other time keepers or
any of the timekeepers returning into
existence if any of those alternate
realities would exist and i think sylvie
is basically
a nexus being a person who could alter
the entire timeline itself
bringing her in and making her a tva
agent keeps that from happening
because now she's not supposed to know
what her true purpose is she would just
go forward as a mindless tva agent doing
whatever it is a judge tells her to do
because the judge works for king the
conqueror the judge is the one who keeps
everything intact and everything
controlled at the whims of king the
conqueror himself
but miss minutes as the last remaining
time keeper
became aware of this and realized what
silvie was
woke her up told her what was actually
happening silvie in turn
led a campaign against the entirety of
the tva specifically
against kang trying to create new
alternate realities each time she tried
the tva stepped in and they used reset
chargers to bring them to an
end the only way to really do this was
to go back in time
or to use the reset chargers and send
them across all these different places
across the time stream and essentially
create
more timelines than the tva could
possibly keep up with creating all of
these alternate realities
regardless of which reality it happens
to be would lead to the time keepers
effectively returning and in turn
taking out king the conqueror or at
least intending to take him out honestly
i don't know if we'll definitively see
that happen
i think the main villain is going to be
the judge and i think that's how it's
all going to play out it's going to come
down to them she's going to be defeated
and much like what you saw with agatha
harkness and wanda vision it's going to
be one of those
you have no idea what you've unleashed
kind of situations and then we'll see it
all sort of come to fruition and doctor
strange
multiverse of madness spider-man far
from home and ant-man and the wasp
quantomania now
having said all that there are huge
holes in this theory so here's what i
want from you guys down in the comments
section
i want you guys to punch a hole punch
every single conceivable hole you can
think of
counter every single point i made here i
would love to see you guys do that it
would be awesome
i'll go through your comments and i'll
look at all the different issues that
are there but i want you guys to punch
every single hole you possibly can i
know you already will
i just want you to try harder so with
that being said guys let me know what
you think down in the comments
and i will catch you all later peace